tenemos aquí una función con valores
vectoriales h y a lo que me refiero
cuando digo que es una función con
valores vectoriales es que si evaluamos
a h en t aquí h está en función de t y
si evaluamos a h en algún valor de t no
nos va a regresar simplemente un número
sino que nos va a regresar un vector en
este caso es un vector con dos
dimensiones esta parte de aquí es el
componente x del vector y esta otra
parte es el componente y ahora como
seguramente ya sabes tenemos muchas
formas de denotar a un vector tenemos
por ejemplo la forma que usan los
ingenieros donde la componente x está
multiplicando a un vector horizontal
tal vez vas a ver a un vector de este
estilo más la componente y 4 t al
cuadrado más 2 t más 1 multiplicando al
vector unitario horizontal así es que
estas son dos formas distintas de
representar al mismo vector
simplemente son notaciones distintas
y muchas veces vamos a ver que estas
funciones tienen esta flecha arriba pero
también muchas veces no les ponemos la
flecha encima y nada más decimos que son
funciones de valores vectoriales pero
bueno ya que terminamos con esto ahora
sí vamos a ver la primera y la segunda
derivada de h con respecto a t vamos a
empezar con h prima de t encontrar esta
derivada es muy sencillo simplemente
tenemos que encontrar la derivada con
respecto a t de cada una de las
componentes si por acá tomamos la
derivada con respecto a t la derivada
con respecto a t bueno pues vamos a
utilizar la regla de las potencias por
aquí tomamos el 5 y lo multiplicamos por
el menos 1 y nos queda menos 5 por t
elevado a las cinco menos 1 o sea
elevado a la potencia 4 y luego la
derivada de menos 6 con respecto a t es
0 entonces es
esta es la tasa de cambio de la
componente x con respecto a t y luego
vamos a la componente i y hacemos lo
mismo
tomamos la derivada con respecto a t y
aquí igual vamos a tener que usar la
regla de las potencias aquí
multiplicamos cuatro por cuatro y nos
queda 16 por t elevado a la 4 - 1 o sea
elevado a la 3 más la derivada de 2 t
que es simplemente 12 y luego la
derivada de 1 con respecto a t pero eso
como ya sabemos es igual a 0 entonces ya
terminamos con esta derivada esta es la
tasa de cambio de la componente x con
respecto a t y esta es la tasa de cambio
de la componente y con respecto a t y
bueno los vectores siempre pueden
representar muchísimas cosas
esto también lo podemos interpretar como
que te es el tiempo y el vector es la
posición en dos dimensiones y entonces
si nos fijamos en la tasa de cambio de
la posición con respecto al tiempo
obtenemos el vector de la velocidad pero
luego si tomamos la tasa de cambio de
este vector con respecto al tiempo lo
que vamos a obtener es el vector de la
aceleración así es que si encontramos h
prima prima del tiempo eso a que es
igual
bueno pues otra vez tenemos que aplicar
la regla de las potencias 4 x menos 5 es
igual a menos 20 x
a la 41 o sea a la 3 y luego 3 por 16
es 48 por t a la 3 menos 12 y luego la
derivada de 12 0 y listo así es que si
tenemos una función como esta y vemos a
t como el tiempo y a estas dos entradas
como la posición la derivada nos va a
dar la velocidad y la segunda derivada
la aceleración aunque también es
importante recordar que estos vectores
pueden representar cualquier cosa que
tenga dos dimensiones